welcome to this video playing
international master vidita this Stefan
docs from Belgium one of them um biggest
improvements in recent years I have
played him years ago in the Belgium leak
when he was still rated above around him
2300 and he's been there for a long
while but then started to improve
rapidly and now is close to being a
grandmaster with the 2500 rating and
over the Boches very young very big
steps forward ok we have a double
fianchetto english dolphin chatter and I
don't really know that too well i
remember this game from the from the
candidates and i think it was to palo
kayaking with roop c7 and rook back to
look back this was g4 and Luke went back
I think if i'm not mistaken hit look see
age 85 height age 594 how interesting
first at first you think i was in this
blundering d6 isn't this in this
blundering d6 what is the point really
I don't understand that okay let's take
it I don't get it now there is no point
probably just blundered it it happens so
you know what the rook is also a bit
unstable maybe I should retreat it and
get in the idea to play Bishop f4
by the way I had played in two times
before here on is SC 5 minute and one
win one loss okay the g5 yeah the g5 was
the idea of all this so I probably
should should play it and now the
question is what is the idea nitey 46
maybe or yeah it looks like it looks
looks like them the way to proceed so
ideally i got i got the bishop rights if
I home yeah if i take it and not a good
idea mean the night on age five is video
side so i shouldn't dumb and shouldn't
help him to try to activate this i canno
i can just play rookie to look you wan
and get them get play on the default
night a foyer maybe still neither form
hmm it's a bit uncomfortable to deal
with that I probably have to take it
okay maybe go on go ahead on the
queenside after all this is why I have
my way I have my pawn who could be six
probably not a move I can go see if I if
I still neither form and then you should
just go back here queen is not bad on
before
germanic smooth some or my plan is to go
see five okay so he's playing it in a
very direct manner getting this night
back into the game maybe even Knight to
g4 jump c5 and not clear that this help
helps me but this could be an idea not
sure way is going now h5 blunders g6
going for the six square very
complicated stuff yeah I didn't really
do do yeah I really didn't punish this
spawn blunder 1d6 it only only got to a
complicated position where basically
everything is possible including a loss
time warning check use the trying to use
the in stable position you have the the
rook rook c7 the idea check check I'm
blundering before No yeah that she can
just take that pawn this was not
necessary at all
no just dem mouse lib and this wasn't
even so clear white resigned yeah my can
I can just take this and let okay when
probably i'm lost but I mean still needs
to do it and then drill that's always
silly to have those mouth lips like this
for example i'm getting a for I mean
okay people probably see that and play
something else but still yeah this is
just a bad loss i mean i was totally
winning of course right after I take t6
and even hear why this still
substantially better this was even okay
Queen B 3 m.r.k check yeah this is not
good it looks fancy but it's not good it
gets the knight to f6 this seems to be
better
yeah it's probably just a good
positioner the bishop is just better on
the wide open board with this King open
tough very tough tough to play the IE
successor really just just blundering it
yeah maybe I could have fun played it
stronger in a way but no 93 4 is also
good young okay yeah what can you do it
was it was pretty much okay what I did I
just spend a bit to be too much of time
that that's clear and I and this is
lucas Sanjay looked looked nice but it
just brought the knight to f6 and while
still there was not much going on of
course I just need to avoid check check
here to blunder before I just play 3 and
I'm fine Tony I'm not better or anything
but I shouldn't really lose it it's
equal material he's got a night which
sometimes can be tricky night and Queen
a answer King word not here i mean i get
i get the bishop over here and not
nothing's happening really and this is
just just a stupid move yeah well I'm
just I'm just I'm just reversed now
giving after having given up this pawn
completely for no reason okay thanks for
watching